Thierry boukarabilla bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes syndicaliste
à force Ouvrière mon du groupe de
travail saisonniers vincentis bonjour
Merci d'être la président de la
commission emploi et formation du
groupement hôtellerie et restauration
Alex nous a rejoint on va parler avec
vous messieurs des conséquences des
émeutes de ces derniers jours sur le
secteur du tourisme y a-t-il eu des
annulations l'image de la France
est-elle dégradée la saison en
touristique est-elle en péril vous ne
direz ce que vous en pensez et puis le
secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration qui
a déjà du mal à recruter comment attirer
le plan saisonnier présenté par le
gouvernement il y a quelques jours
est-il suffisant on ira notamment voir
comment ça se passe du côté de la Corse
à Porto-Vecchio les professionnels
cherchent des solutions pour loger leur
saisonnier d'abord on voit l'actualité
dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Montpellier retrouver Vincent Coste
journaliste à midi libre bonjour Vincent
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
Vincent on va parler tourisme avec vous
puisque évidemment l'Occitanie est une
région très touristique comment
s'annonce cette saison estivale
elle s'annonce plutôt bien le Comité
régional du tourisme de la région
Occitanie justement à dévoilé à la
mi-juin c'est récent des chiffres sur
les sur les premières tendances
journaliste de Midi Libre il y a une
peauvilion à travailler sur ces données
et il savait que depuis le depuis le
début de l'année plus plus 4% de
réservation plus 4% de fréquentation
touristique dans la région un chiffre de
plus 4% qu'on retrouve aussi au niveau
des réservations pour l'hôtel de riz de
plein air qui est très importante dans
notre région avec le littoral
méditerranéen du Languedoc des
Pyrénées-Orientales de l'Hérault du du
Garet et de l'Aude et plus 4% de
réservation également donc pour les pour
les mois de essentiellement bien sûr de
de juillet et août sur le pour
l'hôtellerie de plein air
alors c'est vrai je crois que c'est
votre c'est votre débat ensuite le
Languedoc-Roussillon comme l'Occitanie
comme comme toutes les régions
françaises un lot important d'emplois
vacants dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
pour les saisonniers et ben la
restauration
etc c'est vrai qu'il y avait une
inquiétude également avec les problèmes
de sécheresse très prédire dans notre
région dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
notamment on en a on en a beaucoup parlé
avec des mesures de restriction d'eau
mais apparemment ça ne ça n'influ pas
particulièrement sur les sur les
réservations il y a pas une inquiétude
particulière de la part de la clientèle
d'autres régions pour pour venir pour
venir passer ses vacances cet été
notamment sur le littoral ou ou dans
l'arrière-pays des départements de notre
région avec également deux phénomènes
peut-être plus plus inattendu à signaler
d'abord on retourne massif de patientes
à l'étrangère le plus 13% déjà depuis le
début de l'année la période covid semble
quand même derrière nous il est encore
trop tôt pour dire si les émeutes s'il
est si les événements de ces derniers
jours auront une vraie influence sur le
sur le sur la fréquentation touristique
mais en tout cas la clientèle étrangère
revienne deuxième phénomène au notable
pour cette année 2023 c'est une hausse
de réservation de 24 % pour le mois de
septembre qui est assez spectaculaire et
ça s'explique par la Coupe du monde de
rugby
qui organisait organisé en France et
d'où cette hausse constater pour le pour
le début de l'automne des réservations
dans notre région un niveau inhabituel
pour un mois de au mois de septembre
merci merci beaucoup Vincent d'avoir été
avec nous depuis Montpellier la une du
Midi Libre ce que les mers on va dire
c'est à la Une de votre journal comme de
beaucoup de titres de la presse
régionale on va voir ça à l'ex
évidemment à la fin de ce club merci
beaucoup Vincent Coste d'avoir été avec
nous on va parler de la pénurie de
assaisonner et plus largement d'ailleurs
des difficultés à trouver des emplois
dans ce secteur pour les employeurs des
difficultés à trouver des salariés
pardon d'abord sur l'actualité il y a eu
des émeutes évidemment ces derniers
jours en France est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet des répercussions de ces émeutes
sur le secteur du tourisme effectivement
on est tous uneanime pour que faire le
constat aujourd'hui que les émeutes qui
a eu en tout cas sur tout le territoire
ont eu un impact immédiat en tout cas
sur les restaurants du fait
évidemment et en plus des restrictions
de transport il est évident que ça a eu
un impact tout de suite sur les
réservations sur des annulations voilà
sur les jours qui viennent et là encore
un petit peu même si ça commence un peu
à passer mais en tout cas sur la
restauration ça a eu un impact immédiat
vous arrêtez pas de chiffrer pardon en
moyenne on va dire que ça va de 30% à
60% en fonction de la ville où l'endroit
où on se trouve sur Paris Châtelet par
exemple là où il y a eu des émeutes
importantes on est plutôt aux alentours
de 50%
et sur des même à Rouen où il y a eu des
restaurants qui ont été vandalisés et
autres on se retrouve avec des villes
qui ont des établissements plutôt qui
ont des annulations qui tournent autour
de 30 et 50%. ce qui n'est pas forcément
encore tout de suite le cas pour le
tellerie puisque les réservations et les
clients qui étaient déjà là ne sont pas
forcément partie tout de suite en
revanche en 5e pour l'avenir en tout cas
sur les semaines à venir d'un impact que
ses émeutes vont pouvoir avoir sur des
potentiels qui étaient prévus de venir
on va en parler évidemment est-ce que
vous à force Ouvrière Thierry
boukarabila vous avez aussi senti
l'impact de ces émeutes sur le secteur
du tourisme oui bien évidemment puisque
beaucoup de nos salariés beaucoup de nos
adhérents nous ont fait part de leur
inquiétude quant à voilà leur pérennité
sur le sur leur emploi ça peut aller
malheureusement jusqu'à des restaurants
qui ont été vandalisés et qui sont
contraints à la fermeture à plusieurs
jours voire plusieurs semaines le temps
de établir les travaux et
malheureusement les salariés sont des
victimes collatérales
euh notamment en pleine saison et
d'autant plus que les effectifs étaient
plus ou moins au complet donc oui mais
même côté salarié il y a aussi une
crainte sur sur l'emploi sur la
pérennité de l'emploi dans ces
établissements et d'autant plus qu'elles
sont beaucoup de villes ont été
concernées et du coup vous demandez des
aides de l'État vous souhaitez des aides
de l'État pour faire face à aux
conséquences de ses émeutes sur votre
secteur de l'État je sais pas en tout
cas c'est de faire en sorte que les
assurances soient ultra réactives pour
justement permettre aux établissements
qui ont été victimes de vandalisme et de
pillage de pouvoir réouvrir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
pareil pas forcément des aides de l'État
mais vous comptez sur les assurances
tout dispositif qui permettrait aux
professionnels de pouvoir maintenir leur
activité et maintenir leur salarié
d'éviter à devoir licencier des salariés
en raison de voilà de ces événements
nous conviendrait pas forcément sur la
suite donc là vous nous avez parlé de
l'impact immédiat que vous avez déjà
constaté depuis cette semaine d'émeute
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet pour la
suite de la saison touristique est-ce
que il y a des clients qui est d'ores et
déjà annulent leur séjour qui ne soient
français ou étrangers alors on n'a pas
encore les chiffres réellement je veux
pas pouvoir je vais pas pouvoir dire
aujourd'hui qu'on a réellement des
annulations qui sont qui sont dus aux
émeutes certainement il va y en avoir
c'est pour ça que je vous disais que
l'hôtellerie pour l'instant on n'a pas
réellement de chiffres d'impact sur du
moyen et du long terme on met toute
façon
l'effet l'impact que ça visuellement au
niveau des des pays à l'étranger et
catastrophique à l'arrivée
de la Coupe du monde de rugby et encore
plus des Jeux Olympiques 2024 c'est vrai
que l'image qu'on transmet est
absolument catastrophique encore une
fois donc ça va être un impact
uniquement court terme pour vous mais un
moyen voire long terme il va falloir
qu'on travaille fort pour justement
pallier à cette image qui est véculée
partout dans le monde de ce qui se passe
en France
oui de la même manière que je pense
qu'effectivement l'arrivée de la Coupe
du monde de rugby et des Jeux Olympiques
représentent des normes challenges pour
les secteurs et tous les métiers de
l'hôtellerie qui a fait restauration et
donc c'est un enjeu notamment pour pour
l'emploi et cela passe forcément et par
l'attractivité de ces métiers et par
l'image que renverra la France à travers
le monde mais comment faire on se
souvient que la crise sanitaire avait
été un vrai coup dure pour le secteur du
tourisme évidemment que là la pente
était remontée que les chiffres du
tourisme sont heureux revenus à des
hauts niveaux vous craignez que ça ait à
nouveau un impact sur votre secteur
c'est probable c'est probable que un
moyen terme en tout cas c'est un impact
sur le secteur puisqu'encore l'image
qu'on véhicule est absolument
catastrophique donc c'est probable que
ça puisse avoir un impact maintenant
c'est à nous d'être réactif de faire en
sorte que on puisse véhiculer d'autres
choses communiquer comme il le faut pour
que on redevienne attractif est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet vous nous en parler un
petit peu carabine à tout à l'heure de
l'impact de ses émeutes sur l'emploi
dans l'hôtellerie restauration est-ce
que d'ores et déjà vous savez s'il y a
des saisonniers qui auraient dû être
embauché et qui ne le sont pas parce que
les établissements ont été dégradés
parce que les établissements ne vont pas
ouvrir parce qu'il y aura eu des
conséquences pour les établissements
concernés il y a fort à Paris on a pas
encore de donner très précises étant les
événements étant très récents mais il
est certain que beaucoup de
d'établissements vous avez des rues
commerçants vous avez énormément
d'entreprises liées au secteur qui
forcément ne seront pas en capacité de
de d'offrir des opportunités d'emploi
elle ne serait-ce que pour par rapport à
ce qui leur est arrivé et de manière
plus globale de toute façon les derniers
nous donner près de 77000 plus de 77000
postes de saisonniers non pourvu alors
que la saison est d'ores et déjà entamée
et on va en parler justement de tout ça
parce qu'évidemment ça s'ajoute à des
difficultés de recrutement qui était
déjà présentes et des postes non pourvu
d'abord Alex on va faire le point avec
vous sur les chiffres des besoins de
main d'oeuvre dans le secteur du
tourisme effectivement rien on peut déjà
citer les chiffres de l'été 2022 qui
avait été compliqué en matière de
recrutement pour le secteur il y avait
l'an dernier 150 000 postes de
saisonniers à pourvoir dans l'hôtellerie
restauration et au final seulement la
moitié avait été pourvu et 60% des
hôtels et restaurants avaient du freiné
leur activité à cause de ce problème et
pour cet été ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que la demande de saisonnier est encore
plus forte environ 200 000 postes de
saisonniers dans l'hôtellerie
restauration sont à pourvoir et selon
vos chiffres et bien il y en a encore
77000 qui ne sont pas pourvu donc voilà
la demande est de et en hausse de 30%
par rapport à 2022 on peut dire aussi
qu'il y a certains métiers certains
postes qui sont précisément très
recherchés pour cet été par exemple dans
le secteur de la restauration et bien on
recherche 24 000 postes de cuisiniers et
16500 postes de plongeurs selon les
chiffres de l'agence Adecco et puis il y
a un problème c'est que parmi les
candidats à ces postes qui sont proposés
par Pôle emploi et bien peu sont ceux
qui viennent vraiment aux entretiens
dans le secteur des parcs de loisirs et
d'attractions par exemple sur 15
candidats proposés par Pôle emploi et
bien trois se rendent à l'entretien et
un seul est retenu ce qui traduit cette
difficulté à recruter mais on va parler
de tout ça est-ce que vous attendez un
été 2023 plus difficile encore que l'été
2022 oui malheureusement il y a fort à
parier que d'année en année on voit la
dégradation en termes d'attractivité on
voit les contingents de postes à
pourvoir largement augmenter
à quelques mois d'événements majeurs
comme la Coupe du monde de rugby ou les
Jeux Olympiques on voit d'ores et déjà
toutes les difficultés qu'il y a et la
recherche de solutions alternatives mais
qui malheureusement le résorbe pas
l'intégralité de ses postes qui sont à
pouvoir et donc oui il est triste de
faire le constat que en l'état les
choses ne vont pas s'améliorer seul et
qu'il appartient à tous les acteurs du
secteur de l'hôtellerie qui a fait
restauration de voilà de pouvoir être en
mesure de d'offrir de nouvelles
opportunités de les créer en tout cas et
de tenter de résorber d'année en année
c'était magique tout ça pour vous aussi
vous redoutez une année 2023 un été 2023
plus difficile encore que les
malheureusement
et heureusement j'en fais le même
constat que Thierry qui est que la on a
encore plus cette année une demande
encore plus importante de postes à
pourvoir par rapport à l'année dernière
donc on voit que la demande en tout cas
les clients sont là mais que
malheureusement nos entreprises ne
peuvent pas pallier à ce mot quoi mais
alors comment vous l'expliquez est-ce
que ce sont des questions salariales ce
sont des postes qui sont trop peu payés
ou est-ce que c'est un changement
peut-être dans les mentalités on sait
que l'hôtellerie réparation c'est un
secteur qui est très difficile de jeunes
aujourd'hui qui n'ont plus envie
d'exercer ces métiers alors de sujets
les deux sont une partie de
l'explication vous avez effectivement
une jeune génération qui aspire à des
choses très précises et non pas qu'ils
ne veuille pas travailler dans les
secteurs de l'hôtellerie restauration
mais notamment le travail en coupure ou
le travail du travail et le week-end ou
le travail dominical ils estiment que
c'est en quelques sortes un sacrifice à
leur vie sociale et espère y trouver
compensation et en fait de notre part il
nous pensons que il appartient au métier
de ce secteur de s'adapter à cette
nouvelle génération puisqu'on voit bien
que Sark booter et se dire que c'est ils
ont tort fait que les postes ne sont pas
pourvus il est fort regrettables que les
professionnels doivent se passer d'une
partie de leur chiffre d'affaires
uniquement faute de recrutement alors
comment est-ce que vous attendez comment
ils peuvent s'adapter qu'est-ce que vous
attendez des professionnels des patrons
et bien pour vous donner un exemple il y
avait un groupe de travail qualité de
vie au travail de branche émotionnel qui
malheureusement ne s'est pas réunit
depuis près de 10 mois qui avait quand
même un formidable objectif celui de
mettre en adéquation
les le temps de travail et le temps de
repos des métiers de l'hôtellerie
restauration et de pouvoir y offrir des
des compensations en termes
d'attractivité désormais ça devient plus
urgent d'avancer sur beaucoup de points
de sujets notamment ce groupe de travail
mais comme d'autres comme l'égalité
femme homme comme le réflexion autour du
handicap et notamment il y a un groupe
de travail saisonniers qui se remet en
ordre de marche et qui on espère
aboutira très vite à des choses qui
permettent voilà de juguler cette
hémorragie de post comment répondre à
ces demandes pas une partie viennent de
l'être évoqué là et moi j'ai rajouterais
en plus de ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
qu'on a une vraie révolution managériale
à faire dans notre secteur d'activité
que ce soit au niveau des chefs
d'entreprise eux-mêmes qui gèrent qui
sont à l'exploitation à l'opération que
les directeurs qui sont mis en place on
était dans un vieux modèle archaïque qui
était pyramidal un peu de militaires et
qu'aujourd'hui on voit que tous ceux qui
rejoignent ceux qui veulent rejoindre
notre secteur d'activité ne veulent plus
aujourd'hui là au moins j'étais dans un
mode de carrière et j'étais prêt à
déconcessions aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
que les ceux qui nous rejoignent c'est
pas qu'ils ne veulent plus travailler
c'est pas vrai c'est qu'ils ne veulent
pas faire de gros ils veulent ils
veulent pas faire de concession pour
soit la vie personnelle soit la vie
professionnelle il faut que les deux
salient et puissent se mêler donc à nous
de faire en sorte effectivement de pas
se dire bah c'est comme ça c'est pas
autrement ils doivent s'adapter c'est
plutôt à nous aujourd'hui de faire une
vraie révolution et de faire en sorte
que justement on puisse redevenir
jusqu'au moment parce que par exemple on
prend les restaurants il y a un service
le midi il y a un service le soir ce qui
veut dire forcément des des
horaires hachés pardon comment vous
faites du coup pour répondre à ça il y a
aussi des restaurants ouverts le
dimanche les restaurants qui restent
ouverts tard le soir comment vous faites
du coup pour concrètement je vais parler
de mon cas concrètement avant j'étais
découvert très tôt le matin et j'ai
jusqu'à très tard le soir et 7 jours sur
7 après on regarde son compte
d'exploitation où là où effectivement se
dit est-ce que il y a un intérêt à
ouvrir à 7h du matin pour faire quatre
cafés monopoliser une à deux personnes
on se dit bah potentiellement on peut
peut-être réduire la donc au final on
réduit l'amplitude horaire sans
réellement toucher à avoir un impact sur
le chiffre d'affaires au final on se
retrouve avec forcément des personnes
qu'on peut mettre en queue de coupures
au lieu d'en avoir 5 au lieu d'être
ouvert 7 jours sur 7 on s'aperçoit que
le dimanche soir bon monopolise beaucoup
de personnes pour peu de chiffre
d'affaires et donc on ferme le dimanche
soir et on se retrouve avec avec des
équipes soit les mêmes équipes avec un
impact de chiffre d'affaires qui n'est
pas forcément aussi important que ça et
puis on aménage et puis après et même
chose donc ça veut dire des horaires
d'ouverture resserrer et moins de jours
d'ouverture
c'est pareil quand vous avez une carte
qui est
rallonge qui nécessite si vous en tout
cas vous travaillez des produits faits
frais de faire des mises en place
importante et donc d'avoir du personnel
nombreux en cuisine et du personnel
nombreux en salle pour voir servir ben
on revoit aussi un petit un petit peu de
toute cette partie là
c'est une réponse c'est une partie de la
réponse oui sur les pratiques
managériales parce que certains
professionnels de manière
malheureusement anecdotique mais l'ont
déjà testé comme celle de réduire le
nombre de coupures qu'effectue un
salarié dans la semaine qui lui permet
voilà d'avoir ou des soirées ou des
matinées qu'il consacrent à sa vie à sa
vie privée avant on avait érigé comme un
dogme le fait de devoir absolument
travailler en coupure et le midi et le
soir et on s'aperçoit qu'on peut faire
autrement au travers des pratiques
managériales modernes et d'outils aussi
qui le permettent désormais sans
forcément un coup supplémentaire c'est
juste de mener des réflexions plus fines
sur comment j'adapte mon effectif à
l'activité mais comment aussi Vincent a
juste titre le disait c'est de permettre
de revoir tant la carte que la plage
d'horaire d'ouverture pour pouvoir
certains offrent également de au travers
de deux équipes sans réduction de temps
de travail de pouvoir alterner certains
fonds une semaine en travaillant coupure
et l'autre semaine on continue voilà il
y a quand même plusieurs pistes qui
permettraient justement de répondre aux
attentes personnes génération sur ces
métiers et ça ça pourrait jouer sur le
fait qu'effectivement on a des jeunes
qui veulent de moins en moins sacrifier
leur vie personnelle comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure bien sûr parce que
vous répondez à leur demande le fait de
pouvoir leur laisser l'opportunité de
éventuellement moi j'ai des salariés qui
forcément ne veulent pas deux jours de
repos consécutifs pour des raisons
personnelles parce qu'ils sont soit
séparés de leur conjoint et leur faut
absolument leur dimanche et leur
mercredi pour certains j'en ai qui font
du sport en tout cas au activité ils
veulent absolument le jeudi en jour de
repos donc je m'adapte donc en fait de
leur répondre favorablement fait que
vous fidélisez vos salariés et puis vous
êtes des gens qui sont motivés à
travailler chez vous vous avez senti une
différence dans les aspirations après la
crise sanitaire est-ce que le covid a eu
un véritable impact sur sur les
aspirations genre énormément la période
du covid a été un peu un catalyseur une
prise de conscience pour beaucoup de
salariés qui se sont retrouvés chez eux
notamment
en couple et avec des enfants qui qui
ont touché du doigt un petit peu si vous
peut-être la vie familiale et la vie
autrement et donc on a vu d'ailleurs une
grande désaffection à la fin de la
période du covid dans tous les métiers
de du secteur des HCR et on n'a pas pu à
ce jour on n'a pas encore pu pallier à
toutes ces absences et donc aujourd'hui
quand vous échangez avec cette nouvelle
génération ou même les salariés des
études d'ailleurs le prouve ce qui
arrive en premier de leur souhait c'est
cet équilibre Vie privée vie
professionnelle ou tout du moins il
conçoivent très bien comme vous avez un
établissement Vous êtes salarié d'un
établissement dans le pic d'activité et
le week-end ils comprennent très bien
qu'il faille travailler le week-end mais
il considère ça comme un petit peu une
entorse à cette équilibre Vie privée vie
professionnelle et donc pour certains
aimeraient bien y voir une compensation
ce qui malheureusement n'est pas permis
puisqu'on rappelle que le plus gros
décontageant des salariés des hôtels qui
a fait restaurants restent dans les
premiers niveaux échelons de la grille
de classification
difficulté dans certaines régions en
tout cas pour recruter des saisies il y
a la question du logement c'est le cas
notamment encore puisque c'est encore
plus difficile de les faire venir
puisque les logements manquent pour les
accueillir on va regarder ce reportage
d'Audrey vuettaz du côté de
Porto-Vecchio
dans les bars les restaurants et les
commerces de Porto-Vecchio c'est le
moment le plus important de l'année qui
commence la saison estivale 6000
saisonniers sont attendus en renfort
dans cette commune de 12000 habitants
mais sous le soleil il y a une ombre au
tableau le logement c'est très compliqué
le prix du logement est très cher comme
dans de nombreuses villes touristiques
portent auvecus au compte 65% de
résidence secondaire à cela s'ajoute les
permis de construire qui se donnent
difficilement résultat les locaux ne
parviennent pas à se loger et c'est
encore pire pour les saisonniers t'as
pas trouvé le logement à moins de 800
euros 900 euros par mois sachant qu'on
va pas gagner énormément sur une saison
pour boire et même il faut profiter un
petit peu je peux comprendre que ce soit
un frein alors pour les professionnels
c'est la débrouille Jean-Marc et Tori a
décidé de loger lui-même sa centaine de
saisonniers sur des terrains qu'il ne
peut donc plus utiliser pour étendre ses
hôtels c'est pas compliqué ou vous
faites ça ou vous ne trouvez personne
donc pour le faites et puis bon comme
c'est des personnes qui viennent de loin
elles n'ont pas d'appartement il y a pas
de structure adaptée pour ça
c'est à nous les hôteliers de
comment dire de compenser tout ça sinon
vous nous trouvez personne et donc 100
personnes vous n'êtes pas vous pouvez
dans un spa à quelques encablures elle
est logée dans l'un de ses chalets
mobiles ici
si ça touche salle de toilettes c'est
compliqué dans le sens où tous les
établissements logent pas ça peut être
aussi des établissements qui logent mais
c'est sous ça peut être insalubre ça
arrive souvent ou alors on est très
nombreux dans des espaces par exemple de
la même taille qu'une cuisine mais on va
être 10 pour une petite cuisine comme ça
et là on est bien logé pour attirer des
profils qualifiés c'est aussi le choix
qu'a fait César Filippi cela fonctionne
on serait pas logé personnellement je
serais pas venu je serais pas venu à
Porto-Vecchio mais ce n'est pas sans
conséquence on a eu pour cent de masse
salariale en plus que nos collègues dans
la même catégorie sur le continent alors
les professionnels demandent des mesures
notamment pour encadrer les locations de
meubler touristiques ce qu'on appelle la
paratellerie faut quand même un jour
répondre aux problèmes de la
parootellerie qui vient je dirais sur un
chérir cette cette possibilité de
logements qui la remplaitement
inaccessible pour les salariés en
attendant la mairie vient de lancer un
grand plan logement avec des pistes pour
les saisonniers on a qui déjà une
ancienne résidence hôtelière des
structures qui sont aujourd'hui
peut-être déclassées qui sont plus aux
normes plus adaptées aux exigences du
marché hôtelier mais qui pourraient nous
servir à loger des saisonniers à la clé
des dizaines de logements un début de
solution pour soulager le secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration ou les bras
manquent déjà voilà on le voit alors là
on a un exemple encore mais ça existait
évidemment hier ce sont les hôteliers
qui doivent trouver des solutions
d'hébergement pour attirer leur
saisonniers alors c'est compliqué parce
que quand vous connaissez la pression
immobilière que ce soit sur le continent
ou encore en pierre en Corse je sais pas
si vraiment aujourd'hui le chef
d'entreprise va avoir les moyens de
pouvoir loger en tout cas ces
saisonniers
la possibilité d'avoir les logements
mais en tout cas sur Paris ou même sur
en région que ce soit en montagne c'est
compliqué de pouvoir loger son personnel
maintenant est-ce que c'est au chef
d'entreprise réellement uniquement de
pouvoir
je suis pas je suis pas sûr je pense que
les pouvoirs publics sont aussi à eux de
se préoccupés des territoires des
régions de la mairie parce que si on
regarde la Savoie Haute-Savoie 70% de la
TVA et que est collecter grâce à
tourisme et à saisonniers donc si on
retirait d'un seul coup toute la partie
saisonnière je sais pas je sais pas ce
qui resterait de la montagne donc je
pense que c'est
collectivement qu'il faut se poser le
problème on voit sur tin Val d'iserg il
y a certains chefs d'entreprises qui
au-delà de du logement se sont
préoccupés aussi de la mobilité
c'est-à-dire que c'est bien de pouvoir
loger ses salariés même un peu plus loin
que la station parce qu'on comprend
qu'on préfère louer cher des studios et
des appartements en station pour des des
vacanciers et mettre son personnel un
petit peu plus loin mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut quand même aller les emmener
les ramener avec des crayon noir
créneaux horaires importants le nuit ou
pas et pour certains ça représenté des
sommes pharaoniques
je vous ai vu réagir
de bons enseignements dans votre
reportage et c'est malheureusement nous
nous mais le logement est une
problématique majeure pour l'emploi des
saisonniers et pour l'emploi en général
dans tous les métiers touristiques je
rappelle quand même que tout secteurs
confondus les emplois saisonniers
représentent plus d'un million de cent
mille emplois si vous y ajoutez les
intérimaires saisonniers on dépasse
allègrement les 2 millions d'emplois et
tout un pan de l'économie repose sur ces
salariés donc on ne peut pas je pense
laisser au seul entrepreneurs de pouvoir
se débrouiller parce que on s'aperçoit
que ce n'est pas possible dans tous les
territoires faute de place faute de
choses comme ça c'est étroitement
associé aussi à la mobilité c'est-à-dire
comment vous permettez là aussi de
permettre aux salariés d'accéder
à leur à leur poste vous avez notamment
en montagne ils sont logés dans la
vallée parfois à 30 40 50 km et vous
apprenez que il y a absolument aucune
possibilité de de voilà de ligne de bus
ou autre de moyens de locomotion qui
leur permettent d'arriver à leur poste
il est très étonnant par exemple de voir
sur certains territoires extrêmement
touristiques que les transports en
commun s'arrêtent dès 21h 22h quand on
sait que tous les métiers de
l'hébergement de la restauration on
termine au-delà au-delà de minuit donc
on pense avoir souvenir que c'est une
réflexion qui doit être menée en dans la
plus haut lieu que on voit ici et là
quelques initiatives à la fois des
régions aussi des entrepreneurs mais que
le sujet est-elle qu'il mériterait une
réflexion beaucoup plus profonde autour
des territoires mais également voilà du
du gouvernement pour pour avoir une
vraie politique du logement saisonnier
alors justement
le gouvernement et la présente un plan
il y a un mois pour faciliter le
l'embauche le recrutement des
travailleurs saisonniers on parlait du
logement ça fait partie des principales
mesures de ce plan Alex effectivement il
y a tout un volet de mesure sur le
logement le gouvernement prévoit d'abord
et bien de lancer une plateforme
numérique pour rassembler tous les
offres de logement notamment dans les
parcs de logements sociaux ensuite 2000
logements universitaires vont être
mobilisés cet été pour les saisonniers
cette capacité pour aller jusqu'à 6000
logements universitaires dans les
prochaines années 1000 logements sociaux
vont être agréés d'ici à 2025 à
destination des travailleurs de moins de
30 ans et puis au niveau fiscal et bien
les propriétaires qui louent des biens à
des travailleurs saisonniers seront
toujours exonérés d'impôt sur le revenu
locatif formation il y a une partie
formation effectivement puisque Pôle
Emploi va faire la promotion de
formation courte entre 35 heures et 150
heures sur les connaissances basiques de
la restauration Pôle Emploi devra aussi
accompagner les travailleurs saisonniers
une fois la saison terminée pour les
orienter vers une formation ou un emploi
car on le précise plus de la moitié des
travailleurs saisonniers ne travaillent
pas pendant la période d'intersaison et
donc bénéficie de l'assurance chômage
Thierry ou carabila merci à ce plan
saisonnier il est à la hauteur c'est un
bon début c'est un excellent socle qui
mérite d'être plus ambitieux c'est un
début si je me réfère notamment sur le
logement on voit bien que on parle de
1000 de 2000 logements que c'est
largement insuffisant si je prends
l'exonération sur les revenus locatifs
l'écart est tel que voilà si on sait que
sur des territoires une saison qui on
peut louer entre 1500 et 2000 euros sont
bien il serait très étonnant que ses
propriétaires préfèrent les voilà
bénéficier de l'exonération mais et le
GD des saisonniers donc ce plan doit
absolument être plus ambitieux ce qui
est bien c'est qu'il prend au moins la
mesure du problème et et et défini de
pouvoir le mesurer sur sur trois ans
d'impact et de pouvoir faire déjà un
premier état des lieux qui appel pas
forcément d'autres initiatives vous
citiez par exemple la formation
professionnelle dans ce plan
l'acpme en charge de la formation
professionnelle dans l'hôtellerie qui
avait restaurant et est à l'initiative
de début de projet parce qu'on s'est
aperçu du très peu d'accès à la
formation professionnelle de tous les
saisonniers et du fait que d'année en
année il stagne dans les plus bas niveau
des grilles de classification donc avec
la rémunération faible qui est associée
et donc l'idée ce serait pouvoir réduire
les périodes d'inactivité en partie
grâce à la formation professionnelle
leur permettre là aussi alors qu'ils
n'en bénéficie très peu de bénéficier de
la formation continue et de pouvoir
faire acquérir de nouvelles compétences
et expériences qui qui favoriserait leur
employabilité parfois même sur
différents secteurs ou différentes
métiers dans le même secteur
et la conclusion avec peut-être un mot
sur la question puisque ça va être un
débat d'actualité dans les prochaines
semaines la question des de
l'immigration pour répondre justement à
ces problèmes de recrutement notamment
dans les métiers en tension est-ce que
pour vous c'est une solution ce que
propose le gouvernement à savoir de
d'accorder des titres de séjour pour les
travailleurs étrangers qui travaillent
en ce moment dans personnellement je
suis pas forcément pour donner des
titres des séjours à des personnes
étrangères puisque je pense que on a
déjà un sujet important chez nous
peut-être que Thierry le partage c'est
qu'on a déjà des salariés en situation
régulière qui sont salariés de nos
entreprises donc déjà préoccupons-nous
déjà de pouvoir mettre régulariser ces
personnes qui sont déjà dans nos
entreprises qui travaillent de leur
permettre de pouvoir de monter en
compétences et de laisser de la place à
d'autres personnes avoir même d'aller
chercher du personnel à l'étranger
très vite en fait je suis assez d'accord
avec Vincent puisque il y a d'ores et
déjà ces salariés dans tous les métiers
d'abord qui qui mérite amplement d'être
régularisé mais également de devoir
recourir à des permisses à des titres de
séjour uniquement pour été un aveu
d'échec en soi et que il vaut mieux se
consacrer à l'attractivité des filières
qui permettent aussi d'évoluer au sein
de ces métiers et de pouvoir remettre
comme l'été il y a quelques dizaines
d'années en avant et en exergue ces
beaux métiers des hôtels
café-restaurants
on va regarder ce qu'elle a une de la
presse régionale
[Musique]
et Alex évidemment beaucoup de titres de
la presse régionale consacrée à ces
rassemblements des lieux qui ont eu lieu
hier du vent devant les mairie du pays
mais oui de nombreuses mobilisations
civiques se sont tenues hier midi pour
soutenir les élus qui sont en première
ligne face à ces violences
urbaines c'est à la Une de nombreux
quotidiens régionaux Ouest-France
libération champagne titre uni pour la
République l'appelle au sursaut à la Une
du journal La Provence tous avec les
maires résume Var-Matin ils étaient
nombreux hier notamment à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans le Val-de-Marne aux
côtés du maire Vincent Jean Brun dans le
domicile a été attaqué dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche avec à l'intérieur à
sa femme et ses enfants qui ont dû
s'enfuir Vincent Jean Brun elle a
affirmé hier c'est la démocratie qu'on a
attaqué stop ça suffit a-t-il crié des
mots qui ont été repris par les 30000
personnes qui sont venues le soutenir et
les premières condamnations qui tombent
pour les émeutiers du ferme titres le
journal La Marseillaise alors que le
tribunal de Marseille juge ces jours en
comparution immédiate 87 personnes dont
20 mineurs des peines de plusieurs mois
de prison ferme ont été prononcés pour
certains à Beauvais également le
Courrier Picard raconte l'histoire de
ces jeunes qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
fréquenter les tribunaux comme Benjamin
18 ans jeune homme issu d'une commune
rurale à quelques kilomètres de Beauvais
qui n'a pas un passé délinquant mais qui
s'est retrouvé et bien une nuit avec
plusieurs mineurs à saccager des
commerces dans l'un des quartiers
prioritaires de Beauvais je cite ce
jeune je voulais voir comment c'était
j'avais suivi l'actualité je n'ai pas
réfléchi il est coupé de quatre mois de
prison ferme sous les yeux de sa maman
qui était choquée beaucoup de jeunes
font partie de ces émeutiers mais il y a
aussi des profils très surprenants comme
ce quadragénère qui a pillé le bureau de
tabac d'un centre commercial de Beauvais
là encore je le cite j'agis par pure
opportunisme en plus je connaissais bien
ce bar j'y buvait le café le matin après
ces violences l'enjeu sera de remède
dialogue dans les quartiers
effectivement c'est allé une du journal
l'union de Reims le ministre de à
l'intérieur Gérald de Darmanin s'est
rendu dans le quartier Croix-Rouge à
Reims il a affirmé qu'il fallait parler
au quartier tout en étant ferme avec les
voyous et dans l'union de Reims il y a
un article très intéressant qui compare
deux quartiers populaires de Chalon en
Champagne le premier le quartier labidé
c'était embrasé pendant les émeutes de
2005 il aurait donc pu connaître et bien
des émeutes la semaine dernière mais il
ne s'est rien passé pourquoi parce que
les parents les responsables
d'associations le responsable de la
mosquée et bien organisé des veilles de
nuit pour parler aux jeunes ceux qui les
a dissuadés de brûlé leur quartier puis
le second quartier le quartier Schmidt
qui était plutôt tranquille dans une
zone pavillonne pavillonnaire et bien
lui c'est embrasé car selon le maire de
Chalon Benoît Apparu c'est le dernier
quartier qui n'a pas bénéficié pour
l'instant de politique d'aide au niveau
national 5 secondes il se passe soit sur
la route du Tour aujourd'hui et bien ça
y est depuis hier soir le Tour de France
est arrivé dans l'Hexagone et
aujourd'hui il va entrer dans la région
x Occitanie lors d'une étape entre Dax
et Nogaro avec une arrivée originale sur
un circuit automobile le circuit Paul
Armagnac
merci messieurs d'être venu pour ce
débat merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
pour voir revoir cette émission c'est
sur public sena.fr à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas Hugues et nous
on se retrouve demain
[Musique]